joining us from the picket line at
Houston Station the rmt's general
secretary Mick Lynch Mr Lynch very good
to see you this morning and I I suppose
we have to ask the the very
straightforward question what happens
now given the vote of your membership
well our members have rejected what's
been put to them as has been said and
it's about some of the changes that the
company's proposing which they're going
to start to impose from tomorrow it's
also about the pay deal and their jobs
and that same the same is true on the
train operating company so there are two
halves to this we've been invited by the
Secretary of State Mark Harper
to join a set of discussions with
network rail the executives from the
train operating companies
and uh Trade union will be looking to
get that on as soon as possible and
develop some proposals that our members
can support because what's got to happen
at the end of this dispute to resolve it
is our members will vote on whether they
support a package or not now they
clearly don't support what has been
proposed on network rail we've never had
anything really that we can put to them
from the train operators because they
they're approaching our red lines in
terms of taking all the guards off every
train in Britain they want to close all
the booking offices in the country they
want to cut back on the maintenance
safety regimes by 50 the inspections and
they want to cut thousands of jobs so
we've got a way to go but I can see a
way through where we can get some
improvements in the proposals we can
come to terms with their what they're
calling their modernization agenda I've
heard Andrew Hayden saying we're not
interested in that we're very interested
in reaching a settlement on those
changes but they've got to be through
agreement rather than in position so
there is a way forward the government's
got to facilitate that show a bit of
good wheel so that we can all agree on
what will take the railways forward and
what our members can sign up to
sure it did feel however not that long
ago that there was a deal on the table
that that looked like you could agree to
and then for some reason and you might
be able to explain a little bit more
about this uh you know the real delivery
group had to stick in quotes it had to
stick in Parts about driver-only
operation now had that not happened do
you think that there would have been a
deal done in strikes about it
well I was eating very intensive
negotiations with the train operating
companies and they had removed Clauses
about driver-only operation and on a
Sunday a couple of weeks ago they were
going to put to me a set of proposals
with a pay package which would have been
better than one they actually ended up
proposing and with some changes which
I've said will be challenging for our
Union that we could have then developed
and put to our people at the last minute
the DFT which I think with the
imposition of the treasury and others in
government decided to put into their
driver only operation which the
executives in this industry and the
entire industry knows the rmt can never
accept
so if you're looking for a compromise
you don't put things into a package that
you know your counterpart can never
accept as a red line and as a principle
indeed when you do that to the employers
we don't demand things that they can
never give us we only ask request for
things that are capable of being
delivered so it's the imposition of the
government that has caused the
non-development of a deal and the
non-development of a set of proposals
that we can all work with indeed and
apologies for interrupting the missile
engine but I know we've got a finite
amount of time there's a lot of points
to cover that was a point that I made
directly to the transport secretary this
morning and response there came none but
just reading between the lines there it
does feel that you were willing to
accept the the percentage points that
they were offering you on in terms of
pay I mean is that accurate I mean it is
lower it's certainly lower than
inflation and do you accept that you
will probably have to end up accepting a
less than inflation pay rights
we will not accept the proposals that he
put forward which is four percent for
this year and four percent next year
that is not acceptable because it covers
many of our members having at a pay rise
for three years already so that's way
below what we could accept I'll
negotiate with them what might be
acceptable and what our members could
support but the reason Mark Harper won't
ask that answer that question he
wouldn't answer it at the transport
select committee and he won't answer it
in the media is because he's done it so
if he avoids the question he won't have
to come up with the answer is that he
intervened that if you had one of the
Railway Executives with you or in a
private conversation they will tell you
as they've told me directly that the
government intervened with a set of
proposals that they know cannot be
acceptable because they want these
strikes to go ahead the same way that
they're treating the nurses yesterday
they won't even discuss their pay
they're making enemies of working people
they're making enemies of trade unions
and they're making any is of the public
I think because this is a campaign of
disruption brought around through Rishi
sunak's attitude Chancellor Hunt's
attitude which is to make working people
poorer and to maintain the living
standards of the rich that's what it's
about at the end of the day and they've
got to come off that position and get to
a decent set of proposals that we can
all compromise on and get a settlement
to the dispute I mean Mr Lynch what
level of support are you getting from
the labor front bench at the moment
Whoa We Get Low a front bench saying
that they support our right to the
strike that doesn't butter any parsnips
as the labor front bench on on our
picket lines there's plenty of Labor MPS
who are but there'll be a lot of
working-class people who are asking when
the election comes where were you in 22
what were you doing to support
working-class people in their struggles
so postal workers are out in heavy
numbers having their contracts ripped up
medical staff and their health workers
and our Educators our care workers our
firefighters are all asking where the
labor party front benches if they want
our votes in an election they might want
to come and stand next to us when we're
struggling with austerity when we're
struggling with low pay and people who
are in work are having to use food banks
and live in cold housing and substandard
conditions because of what this
government's doing to us while the
shadow Chancellor and the leader of the
opposition sits on his hands and
triangulates around the problems they
can't avoid the problem
because if he wants to be a leader of
the working class he's got to show he
identifies with the working class
doesn't butter any Parcels that's a
phrase I haven't heard in a couple of
years thanks for reminding me and thanks
for joining us Mick Lynch good to see
you